there's a warning tonight about a
growing problem across the state the
nevada labor commission is seeing an
uptick in worker claims about missed
meals and breaks christian casada is
joining in us in studio tonight with
what is causing this concern and what
you can do about it kristin well denise
it's a common problem according to the
state that is growing because of the
pandemic employees and employers are
being asked to step up and do more than
they usually do they say that is causing
a strain all around now we spoke to the
nevada labor commission today and they
tell us they've seen an influx of claims
over a variety of issues caused by the
pandemic they say each case is being
addressed in the order it is received
and they are encouraging anyone anyone
in doubt to review their website
labor.nv.gov
there you can find information about
common questions like wages and lunch
breaks also a reminder nevada law states
employers must provide in a 10-minute
rest period uninterrupted for every four
hours of work and a meal period of at
least 30 minutes when working for a
continuing period of eight hours
in regards to employees if they feel
that they are
being overworked or um
not being able to take proper breaks
they can also contact our office we're
here to inform them of what their laws
are
we'll remember that you can submit a
claim anonymously meaning no information
needs to be provided by the person just
details about the business and the
alleged violation also nevada is an at
will state meaning anyone can be
terminated or quit for any reason or no
reason at all now we have more
information about this on our website
right now eight newsnow dot com
christian cassette is live local now